اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر من كل زوايا
مع بطئ الهجوم بطئ الصور كمان
مع بطئ الهجوم المضاد سيل اسئله عن جدوى
دعم الغربي لكياف وموسكو تراهن على الوقت
وفاعليه التحصينات
تقنياتها العسكريه وصلت لروسيا وخفر
سواحلها في بحر الصين تحول لاسطول حربي
يميت
عشيه بدر محاكمته في قضيه الوثائق ترامب
يقول انه لن يستسلم لاستبداد اليسار
وانصاره يدعون للتظاهر
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
ايطاليا تودع
السياسه وامبراطور الاقتصاد وميلوني توشيد
بتاثيره التاريخي
[موسيقى]
ننتقل مباشره الى هذه الصور المباشره
لوصول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب الى ميامي في فلوريد حيث من المفترض
ان يمثل لاول مره امام محكمه
فيدراليه في يعني وسيكون هناك جلسه استماع
بشان هذه الوثائق السريه وهناك طبعا
تصريحات
لمحاميه ولحلفائه يتحدثون عن انه هذه
المواد يعني ليست بالمعنى السري الذي
يحاول يعني الادعاء ان يروج له فيما
الادعاء والطرف الاخر يقول بان هذه كان
يجب ان تنقل وان وجهت اليه يعني كانت يجب
ان تنقل الى الارشيف الوطني ووجهت اليه
لطلبات في هذا الشان ولكنه لم يمتثل صحيح
يا طاهر يعني ترامبا وكما نشاهد في هذه
الصور سينزل بعد قليل من طائرته الى
فلوريدا للاستماع بشان الوثائق السريه
طبعا هذه اول مره رئيس امريكي يواجه هكذا
التهم ويصل الى هذه المرحله كان هناك
التصريح لشرطه ميامي
اعلنت فيها عن الجاهزيه للتعامل مع اي
احتجاجات قد تقع في جلسه الاستماع
لترامب لانه انصار يعتبرون بانه هذا جزء
من حقوقه الاحتفاظ بمستندات تسميه محاميه
ترامب تذكارات شخصيه او وثائق رفعت عنها
السريه متهمين الاطراف المعاديه الاخرى او
الخصم الاخر اي الحزب الديمقراطي بانه
يقوم بملاحقات يصفونها بالسياسيه فيما
ينفي الحزب الديمقراطي او اداره الرئيس
بايدن ان تكون هذه الملاحقات السياسيه
طبعا كشف كان منذ ايام عن لائحه الاتهام
الفيدراليه يا طاهر الموجهه للرئيس
الامريكي
البقدونس حيث وجهت له 37
التهمه تتعلق طبعا بحيازه وثائق سريه دون
تصريح وعرقله سير العداله بالاضافه الى
اخفاء الوثائق والادلاء ببيانات كاذبه
امام سلطات انفاذ القانون وكل تهمه من هذه
التهم يعني عليها عقوبات تشمل بطبيعه
الحال غرامات كبيره وامكانيه قضاء سنوات
في السجن في ظل يعني اصرار دونالد ترامب
على خوض السباق الرئاسي فهل ستعرقل هذه
التهم في جلسه الاستماع ان تم يعني تثبيت
التهم عليه وصوله الى البيت الابيض
للمره الثانيه لا نعرف ذلك كان الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب راويه قال انه هو
ضحيه حمله اضطهاد كما سماها مخاطبا
انصاروا للمره الاولى عندما بعد ان وجه
اليه القضاء الفيدرالي الامريكي اتهامات
قد يكون لها كما قلت انعكاسات على
الانتخابات التمهيديه بين الجمهوريين
انفسهم قبل الانتقال ايضا الى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في عشرين اربعه وعشرين
يعني طبعا قال لو لم اكن مرشحا لما كانت
هناك حمله اضطهاد كما سماها ولا ما كانت
هناك لائحه اتهام هذا عندما تحدث امام
نشطاء مجتمعين في كولومبوس بولايه جورجيا
اذا الان نحن امام وصول الرئيس السابق الى
فلوريدا للاستماع لحضور جلسه الاستماع
بشان الوثائق السريه كما يقول الادعاء
وهناك طبعا دعوات من انصاره للتظاهر
والتجهر احتجاجا على ذلك طبعا كان هناك
تساؤلات حول تفاصيل هذه الوثائق
لنعرف لاحقا بانها تشمل بعض التفاصيل حول
برامج الاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه ونقاط
الضعف المحتمله
للولايات المتحده وايضا حلفائها وخطط
واشنطن لشن هجمات عسكريه انتقاميه لانه
الكشف طاهر عن هكذا وثائق وتفاصيل قد يعرض
الامن القومي
الامريكي للخطر بطبيعه الحال وايضا
المعلومات العسكريه وسلامه الجواسيس اذا
صح التعبير طبعا يعني العنوان الابرز قد
يكون لهذه المحاكمه وجلسات الاستماع هي
بانها محاكمه سياسيه تاتي في وقت حساس
وهناك مخاوف جديه من
التكرار احداث الكابيتال لذلك هناك جهزيه
كامله للتعامل مع اي احتجاجات من قبل
مناصري ترامبلين دائما ما يتفاعلوا بطريقه
مباشره مع اي تصريح للترامب على الارض
بوزير العدل السابق للبارك كان يعني ينتقد
ترامب في الفتره الاخيره بعد او رغم انه
عمل معه سابقا قال ان لائحه الاتهام مفصله
للغايه واعتبر ان فكره ان الرئيس لديه
السلطه الكامله لتصنيف اي وثيقه على انها
شخصيه فكره سخيفه طبعا هذا يزيد يزيد من
حجم الشرخ الموجود بين الحزبين وبين
التوجهين التوجه الاخر الذي بدا يصفه الان
باستبداد اليسار في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قاصدا قيادات ديمقراطيه في
السلطه حاليا يعني
اما من يعني يؤيد ترامب في هذا فيقول بانه
الطرف الاخر
يسلك طريقا ثم يجرب اخر ثم يستمر في
ملاحقته وان هذه المحاكمه من تدبير معسكر
الرئيس الديمقراطي جو بايدن رغم رغم راويه
انه هذه اللائحه طبعا تعرفين بانه
تتبناها هيئه محلفين كبرى في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وفيها يعني مواطنون وفيها قضاء يشمل
القضاء الامريكي
بغض النظر عن الاراء السياسيه في ذلك نعم
اذا نحن
بانتظار خروج الرئيس ترامب خلال لحظات من
الطائره
للمشاركه في جلسه الاستماع بشان الوثائق
السريه لشك يعني هي لحظات استثنائيه
نعيشها اليوم فتح الباب ها هو الرئيس
دونالد ترامب ينزل من على درج الطائره حيث
لاول مره يتم فيها اتهام رئيس سابق ومرشح
بارز للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه عام
2024 امام الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن ب 37
تهمه جنائيه
قانون التجسس
الادلاء ببيانات كاذبه رقم 37 يتكرر ايضا
باستطلاع راي اجراها معهد ابسوس وشبكه اي
بي سي نيوز كان نشر يوم الاحد 47% من
المشاركين اعتبروا بانه التهم الوارده في
القضيه ذات دوافع سياسيه اما 37 بالمئه
فلا يعتقدون ذلك يعتقد ايضا 61 بالمئه من
المستطلع ارائهم ان الدعوه القضائيه ضد
ترامب جديه جدا
مقابل يعني عدد اخر اقل لا يعتبر ذلك جديا
جدا انما جديه الى حد ما وفقا لاخر
استطلاعات الراي يعني طاهر هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتم فيها الاستماع الى دونالد
ترامب كلنا نتذكر منذ اسابيع او اشهر
قليله وهو الان يعني وفد او سيارات دون
التروم تتحرك نحو
المحكمه للاستماع بشان الوثائق السريه
يعني المتاعب القضائيه كما كنت اذكر لم
تنتهي عند هذا الحد هناك تحقيقات لا يتم
او ما يزال على ترامب عبورها
في ولايه جورج تحديدا لتغيير نتائج
الانتخابات بعام 2020 الى جانب تحقيقات
بشان دوره في هجمات السادس من يناير عام
2021 على مبنى الكابيتال بهدف عرقله
التصويت على فوز الرئيس جو بايد
الانتخابات عام 2020 ذكرنا قبل قليل يعني
بعضا مما يعارض ترامب وما يقوله نقول الان
بانه رئيس مجلس النواب المقارثي قال اقف
مثل جميع الامريكيين الذين يؤمنون
بالسياده القانون مع الرئيس ترامب اما
الرئيس اللجنه القضائيه في المجلس جيم
جوردن فقال انه يوم حزين لامريكا راندي
سانتس اللي ممكن يكون احد منافس سي ترامب
الرئيسيين في الحزب الجمهوري لنيل الحزب
للرئاسه كرر انتقادات ترامب لوزاره العدل
معتبرا انها اداه يعني في مواضيع ايضا لا
يمكن ان يكون خصمين فيها لانه في قاعده
جمهوريه قاعده حزبيه عريضه يتنافسان على
النايل اصواتها طبعا السؤال الابرز طاهر
الان هل ستنتهي هذه المحاكمات قبل
الانتخابات وكيف ستؤثر
جلسات الاستماع هذه او القضايا المتهم
فيها
ترامب على الانتخابات وراي الجمهور سنكون
بتفاصيل اكثر حول هذه هذا الموضوع هذا
الملف خلال حلقتنا لليوم معنا ايضا يعني
ضيفين واحد عن الجانب الجمهوري واخر عن
الجانب الديمقراطي طبعا
ونقل مباشر دائما
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لا يزال
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يبحث عن ثغره
واضحه في الدفاعات الروسيه كي ينفذ منها
بكثافه ويعلن عن بدء تسجيل التحول المامول
في مسار الحرب في المقابل يترقب الروسي
مسار القطعه العسكريه الاوكرانيه كي يقرر
اين سيركز دفاعاته وبين الاثنين يترقب
الغرب مسار المعركه كي يحدد ما اذا كان
سيستمر في اغلاق السلاح على كاف او يدفعها
ويندفع معها نحو الحوار المر مع الساكن
الكراميل
اذا اعلنت اوكرانيا انها سيطرت على سبع
قرى في اقليم منذ بدات هجومها المضاد
وكانت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هانا
ماليار افادت بان القوات الاوكرانيه تقدمت
لمئات الامتار باتجاه مدينه باخموت فيما
اوضح مسؤولون عسكريون ان القوات الروسيه
قصفت مواقعهم باكثر من 200 مره بينما دمرت
القوات الاوكرانيه مركبتين قتاليتين
تابعتين للقوات الروسيه ومدفعيها
ومستودعه ذخيره ميدانيا
في المقابل اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها صدت محاولاتي القوات الاوكرانيه
لمهاجمه منطقتي دنيا
تدمرت اهدافا عاليه الدقه اطلقتها من
البحر
هذا وطلب قائد قوات فاجنر
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالتركيز على وضع
خطه لصد الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بدلا من
بدلا من اصدار قرارات حول القوات المتطوعه
في القتال باوكرانيا واكد قائد فاجنر انه
لا يريد التصعيد مع وزاره الدفاع بعد
قرارها الاخير بضروره توقيع المتطوعين
عقودا معها بحلول نهايه الشهر الحالي وهو
القرار الذي استجابت له القوات الشيشانيه
المعروفه باسم اخمد
اذا هذا ما يقوله الجانبان ولكن ما الذي
تقوله التقارير الغربيه القوات الاوكرانيه
تواصل مساعيها للتقدم في بعض المناطق شرق
البلاد وتتكبد خسائر لكن الحديث عن تاثير
الهجوم المضاد لا يزال مبكرا للغايه قوه
كياف المسلحه باسلحه غربيه وفي بحثها عن
نقاط ضعف في الخطوط الروسيه كسبت بعض
البلدات وخسرت بعض الاسلحه الغربيه
والدبابات منها تحديدا روسيا اعلنت عن
تدمير دببتين صنع واربعا من ناقلات عن
تدمير اربع من ناقلات الجند الامريكيه من
طراز برادلي كما تم التخلي عن مركبات
مدرعه اخرى امريكيه وفرنسيه خبراء عسكريون
ارجعوا عدم تحقيق اوكرانيا مكاسب كبيره
للاستعدادات الروسيه منذ اشهر للهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني وايضا الاستخدام
اوكرانيا عددا صغيرا من القوات فقط خطوط
الدفاع الروسيه صممت لايقاف الاوكرانيين
لاطول فتره ممكنه حتى تتمكن موسكو من
تعزيز دفاعاتها بشكل اكبر وهنا يقع على
القوات الاوكرانيه المتقدمه يقع عبء
اختراق شبكه معقده من الدفاعات الروسيه
التي تمتد مئات الكيلومترات في شرق
اوكرانيا على خطوط التماس في مناطق
السيطره الروسيه الدفاعات الروسيه وفقا
لضابط استخبارات اوكراني تتكون من ثلاثه
خطوط وبمستويات متفاوته من التحصينات التي
يمكن ان يتجاوز عرضها في بعض المناطق 30
كيلومترا كجزء من التحصينات الروسيه بحسب
اكياف او جزء من هذه التحصينات الروسيه
بحسب كيف يتكون من خنادق بعمق اربعه امتار
وعرض سته امتار مضاده للدبابات مع وجود
العوائق الكونكريتيه اضافه للاسلاك
الشائكه والالغام التي ربما تمتد عبر خط
المواجهه باكمله من شبه جزيره القرم وحتى
كامل مساحه الشرق الاوكرانيه ينضم الينا
من خرسون الان الدبلوماسي السابق
والمستشار السابق لحاكم خيرسون فلو
شوماكوفا اهلا بك معنا استاذ في العربيه
360 الى اي مدى يعني تعتقد بانه هذه
الانتقادات الموجهه للهجوم المضاد الذي
تخوده اوكرانيا حاليا منطقيه وواقعيه ويجب
التعامل معها من قبل القياده الاوكرانيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تحيه من مدينه خرسانه نعم بصفه
كما يقولون كبار هنا في اوكرانيا بان
اوكرانيا
الان نحن نشاهد في بعض الاماكن عملياته
وكمان في ابعاد المناكير مناطق الاستطلاعه
القتالي قوه مصالحه اوكرانيا بصراحه كمان
سؤال مطروح على طاوله هل سوف يكون انهيار
جبهه روسيه في ظل هجوم مضاد للقوات مصالحه
اوكرانيه على نطاق الواصل سوف نرى في اقرب
وقت اكيد موجود الى شفه شديده الاوكرانيه
وكمان بسبب الالغام هنا في منطقه وكمان في
محافظه
روسيا الزرع الضخم من الالغام وهي اكيده
تعرقله هجوم مضادات القوات مصالحه
اوكرانيه في كل المناطق
اولا انا اكيد قوات تدمير هذا
هجوم وقوات المصالحه اوكرانيه في منطقه
خيار بصراحه هذا الكارثه هنا في اوكرانيا
هذا تدمير هذا
الكارثه
كمان هذا اضرار ليس فقط لمحافظه
لمحافظه وخاصه ادرار اقتصادي معروف
بالمدينه كليبريه معتمده مياه الحوض
النظافه وفي هذا المنطقه
حديثه
نحن سوف نراه في اقرب الوقت تقريبا بعض
اسبوع اسبوعين وهذا الصوف ستكون عواقب
وخيمه
الشديد بالمناسبه لانه موجود معلومات الان
روسيا فاخره مصنع تيتانا موقع على حدود
شبه زيرو
ومحافظه خرسون يعني في هذا التدمير هذا
المصنع سوف تكون الكارثه البيئيه الثانيه
في هذا المنطقه في محافظه الخيرسون هذا
مصنعه هي تنتاج
من الاحماض وكمان من روسيا مستعده لتدمير
المنشات كريتيكيه هنا في اوكرانيا منشات
مهامه
مضاده لاوكرانيا بانها هي التي تحاول عبر
بعض اجهزتها واجنحتها ان تقوم بمثل هذه
العمليات لكي تتهم موسكو يعني تضعها في في
ركن في زاويه امام المجتمع الغربي والدولي
بانها هي التي تقوم بمثل هذه العمليات
الخطيره ما رايك
بصراحه ليس في صالح اوكرانيا نعم تنفيذ
مثل هذا الكارثه كما يدور حديث عن الصاد
تدمير الصاد فينا باقي اخوك وكمان تدمير
خطوط الانابيب المونيا محافظه الخارجيه
يعني
كما نحن نقول بان ان هذا تدمير هذا الساط
ممكن ان نقارنه مثل اسلحه دمار الشامل في
هذا اللي فيها في هذا سبق او في هذا الضوء
سيد بوتين هو ما يهتم باستخدام حتى اصلح
نوويه لان تدمير مثل هذا الصادر تدمير
كمان محطه نوويه زبوريه وهذا كمان اسلحه
الجانب الروسي السيد فلديمير يقول بانه
متضرر من تدمير هذا سد على كل الاحوال
تفضل بالبقاء معنا سنتوقف طاهر مع هذا
التصريح الهام السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جازف بارل الذي قال ان
اي مفاوضات سلام بشان اوكرانيا لن تحدث
قبل تحديد الفائز في انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه في العام 2020
واضاف بريال ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ينتظرون نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه
مشيرا الى انه لا يجب توقع بدء مفاوضات
السلام قبل ذلك
لكن من الواضح ان توقيت التفاوض ليس
مرتبطا فقط بتحديد هويه الرئيس الامريكي
اليس كذلك وانما بسير المعارك على الارض
خاصه في ظل مكاسب اوكرانيه تعتبر صغيره
مقارنه بحجم ما تلقته كياف من اسلحه
تكتمت كييف على انطلاقه هجومها المضاد لكن
ملامحه كانت واضحه منذ ايام
سن وعشرون معركه تحدث عنها الجيش
الاوكراني بالقرب من بخمه شرقي البلاد
وجنوبا بالقرب من افديفكا ومارينكا في
دونسك وقرب بلوهوريفكا في منطقه لوغانسك
وفق رويترز
ميدانيا حققت القوات الاوكرانيه مكاسب في
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
مكاسب وصفاتها صحيفه وول ستريت جونل
الامريكيه بالصغيره مقارنه بحجم الاستعداد
وتسليح الغربي طيله الاشهر الماضيه
بحسب الصحيفه فان الهجمات الاولى كانت
مكلفه حيث دمرت مركبات قتال ودبابات اضافه
الى تخلي القوات الاوكرانيه عن ناقله جندن
ومركبه قتاليه لكن تمت التفوق لاسلحه
القوات الاوكرانيه الغربيه على الروسيه
خصوصا في الهجمات والعمليات الليليه
فالاوكرانيون اختاروا الهجوم ليلا لتقليل
فعاليات القوات الجويه الروسيه وتجنب
هجمات المسيرات وفق تقرير لصحيفه
الليبراسيون الفرنسيه غير ان المعادله
تتغير نهارا فتنكشف تحركات الاوكران
انكشاف مكن الروس من تحقيق ضربات مباشره
لدبابات ومركبات المانيه وامريكيه الصنع
استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه كييف اعترفت
بذلك لكنها قللت من حجم خسائرها
خسائر دفعت بيكييف للطلب من المانيا زياده
عدد الدبابات ليوبارد الى ثلاثه اضعاف
اضافه الى مركبات قتاليه وصواريخ كروز
بعيده المدى
الينا طبعا من جديد من خرسون الدبلوماسي
السابق والمستشار الحاكم خرسون اهلا بك من
جديد السيد يعني هل الى هذه الدرجه هذا
الهجوم المضاد مهم ومفصلي بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا حتى انه الغرب ينتظر نتائجه
ليحكم ويقرر على اساسها المفاوضات
الوقت في الصالخ اوكرانيا ومن الضروري طرد
الروس في اقرب الوقت من اراضي اوكرانيا
للاسف الشديد انا اعتقد بان سوف اوكرانيا
سوف تحتاج الى عيد هجومات ومضادات على جيش
روسي لطارق كلهم من
دون باس من جنوب اوكرانيا وايضا من شبه
الجزيره محاوله مفاوضات مع روسيا نحن
نشاهد بانه ممكن روسيا يطلب المفاوضات
ولكن هو لا يطمعه السلام ها هي نقطه
الجوهريه روسيا سوف تستخدم هذه ماهله
لتعزيز قواتها تحقيق
ذلك روسيا سوف تهاجمها على اوكرانيا لماذا
لان هدف اسعس عن ضروسه هذا عدم خروج
اوكرانيا من منطقه نفوس روسيه بهذا صعبه
روسيا هجمت في بدايه الحرب على كيف هدف
اساسي
اذا ما قرر الغرب وقف او تخفيف مساعدتكم
ما ردك
كما انا قلت وقت ليس في الصالح اوكرانيا
دروس في اقرب الوقت
اوكرانيا
لم تحصل على منقتلات من دراسه في اوكرانيا
لم تحصل على الدبابات من طراس ابرامس
امريكيه ولم تحصل على صواريخ بعيده ماده
ولكن على كل حال دعونا نتذاكر بان في سنه
ونحن الان نشاهد بان من الممكن سوف يكون
المرشحه الجديد هو نحن نراجع عنه
طموحات سياسيه كبيره على كل حال انا اعتقد
بان الساناجيه سانا القادمه سوف تكون صعبه
لاوكرانيا على كل حال وكما نقول اوكرانيا
تحتاج في طائر دروس في اكروبوليفار من
اراد اوكرانيا بهذا السبب اوكرانيا تطلب
من من
على اسلحه وتقديم لاوكرانيا
ومساعده بالمناسبه للاسف الشديد روسيا
دمرت اقتصاد اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تقريبا
30% من اقتصادنا خطا اكثر الان وبهذا
تحتاج الدعم
اقتصادي والمالي من
مناسبه الذهبيه لاوكرانيا انضمام الى
خطا اذا انتهت حرب اوكرانيا عند اوكرانيا
سوف تفوز
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
كشف تقرير اعده محققون غربيون نقله صحيفه
امداد روسيا بالمسيرات وقال المحققون في
التقرير انه تم رصد مكونات صينيه في مسيره
ايرانيه استخدمتها روسيا خلال الحرب في
اوكرانيا
واضافوا ان المكونات الصينيه في المسيره
تم صنعها في منتصف يناير الماضي واشارت
تقرير الى السرعه التي تم فيها تصنيع
المكون الصيني في يناير ثم شحنه الى ايران
وتركيبه هناك وارسال المسيره الى روسيا
واستخدامها في الحرب في ابريل الماضي
التقرير الذي اعده محققون في شركه تتخذ من
بريطانيا مقرا لها ومتخصصه في تعقب حركه
الاسلحه عالميا اكد ايضا ان الصين مستمره
في شحن مكونات المسيرات لايران
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
لا مؤشرات على ارسال الصين اسلحه لروسيا
كم عبر بلينكن عن قلقي بلاده بشان توفير
شركات صينيه تكنولوجيا عسكريه لروسيا
وفي ملف اخر يا طاهر يحمل خلافا بين
الطرفين تواصل الصين زياده عديد قطعها
البحريه في الممرات المائيه الاستراتيجيه
مقد يقود ويقود لسباق تسلح جديد نشرت بكين
اسطولا من السفن البيضاء المجهزه بمدافع
وصواريخ مضاده للسفن لكنها ليست تابعه
للبحريه الصينيه وبهذا تكون الصين بحسب
استغلت المنطقه الرماديه هذه المنطقه
الفاصله بين السلطات انفاذ القانون
والقوات البحريه في الفتره بين الثلاثين
من مارس الماضي وحتى الثاني من ابريل
احاطت سفن خفر السواحل الصينيه بجزر
سيمكاكو المتنازع عليها مع اليابان لاكثر
من 80 ساعه لتعلن اليابان لاحقا عن خطه
لتطوير خفي السواحل وضمه الى وزاره الدفاع
نيويورك تايمز اعادت التفكير بسعي الصين
لتصبح قوه بحريه عظمى وقيام الرئيس في
عامه الاول كرئيس للصين بانشاء قوه بحريه
من خلال دمج خمس جهات مختلفه طبعا سيكون
خفر السواحل في نظر الصين اساسا يساعدها
على التحكم في الممرات المائيه المهمه
وثرواتها المائيه والسمكيه وايضا المعدنيه
وهو ما قاده لاحتكاكات مع قوات خفر
السواحل وسفن صيادين ايضا في كل من
الفلبين وفياتنام وايضا اندونيسيا مؤخرا
وسعت الصين المهمه والقدره القتاليه
لاسطولها بعد اقرار قانون عام 2021 الذي
يمنع خفر السواحل حق استخدام القوه
المميته ضد السفن الاجنبيه يرى خبراء ان
الصين بذلك تنتهك القانون الدولي من خلال
السماح لخفر السواح البن انخراطي في سلوك
حربي دون اعلان الحرب وخارج نطاق سلطتها
[موسيقى]
اذا البيت الابيض يقول للعربيه مصرون على
دبلوماسيه لحل الازمه في السودان وسنتابع
هذا الموضوع بتفاصيله في 360 نتابع ايضا
اذا
مع تدهور الوضع على الارض الامم المتحده
تعلن عن مؤتمر لدعم الاستجابه الانسانيه
في السودان الموضوع نفسه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وصل رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامبيلا فلوريدا كما
تابعنا في بدايه العربيه 360 لحضور اولى
جلسات المحاكمه في قضيه الوثائق السريه
وكانت شامبا قال عبر منصته التروسوش لانه
يامل ان يشاهد الشعب الامريكي بكامله ما
يفعله اقصى اليسار بالبلاد المتحده بانها
في حاله تدهور خطير ومستمر كما اعتبر
اعتبر ان الصين استولت على كوبا وان هذا
ما كان ليحدث تحت اداره جديده من البيت
الابيض فيما يتعلق بكوبا تحديدا الموضوع
اللي عم يحاول
ان يتحدث عنه في هذا الصدد كما اشرت قبل
قليل والبيت الابيض يقول في تصريحاته بانه
ابلغ كوبا الحكومه الكوبيه بقلقه ومخاوفه
حول ما يسميها ايواء كوبا لقاعده تجسس
صينيه
كان انصار الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب دعوا للاحتجاج امام محكمه ميامي
بولايه فلوريدا وذلك رفضا لتوجيه
الاتهامات بحق ترامب السعي للعوده الى
البيت الابيض حيث اعتبر انصاره انها تستند
الى دوافع سياسيه
فيما تتجه الانظار الى ميامي حيث سيمثل
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام محكمه
فيها يعمل الاخير على اظهار المواجهه مع
خصومه وكانها مع الشيوعيين واليسريين
والماركسيين على حد وصفه وصف ترامب جاء في
اعلان له على سوشيال حيث اوضح انه يتحضر
للتوجه الى دولار في ميامي مؤكدا على
ضروره البقاء مع انصاره اقوياء وهزيمه
هؤلاء الخصومه الذين اتهمهم بتدمير
الولايات المتحده بشكل ممنهج
يريد ان يظهر وكانه يواجه اعداء امريكا
المحاكمه تاتي من هؤلاء الشيوعيين او
الماركسيين لذا فهو يحاول تصوير المدعين
ليس كاعداء الله فحسب بل اعداء للولايات
المتحده يعتقد انه وامريكا واحد
ومع تصاعد الجدل بين انصار ترامب وخصومه
بعد توجيهه لائحه اتهام من 37 تهمه للرئيس
السابق تتزايد مخاوف حدوث اعمال عنف سياسي
خاصه بعد تغريده النائب الجمهوري المؤيد
له انديبز التي قال فيها ان البلاد وصلت
الى مرحله الحرب
انه بالتاكيد شيء مقلق عندما يتصاعد خطاب
هؤلاء السياسيين اكثر فاكثر كما تسمع ايضا
مالكي الاسلحه وموقفهم ولا يساعد هذا في
خفض التصعيد والجمهوريين بحاجه الى اعتبار
ان كلماتهم قد تكون خطيره اذا راينا عنفا
سياسيا في الايام المقبله
في غضون ذلك يصر ترامب رغم توجيه لائحه
الاتهامات الفيدراليه له على اكمال حملته
للحصول على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري ومنددا
بما يصفه بحمله الاضطهاد ضده وتسييس وزاره
العدل للقضاء حسين العربيه واشنطن
ينضم الينا من واشنطن اسامه سبلاني
اهلا بك من واشنطن ايضا البحث شؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه استاذ ايهاب
عباس اهلا بكمام دعني ابدا معك استاذ
اسامه وكيف يمكن ان يفهم المشاهد العربي
طبيعه الردود الديمقراطيه ومن اداره بايضا
ضد الاتهامات التي يوكيلها الجمهوريون او
ترامبيون تحديدا ضد هذه الاداره وضد الحزب
الجمهوري بمحاوله اجراء محاكمات سياسيه
لها علاقه بتاثير على الانتخابات المقبله
طبعا الذي يحصل اليوم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو جديد واستثنائي لم يحدث حتى
في هذا في القرن الماضي حتى في حتى حتى
هذا القرن يعني هذا الشيء جديد وانقسام
عمودي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
المفترض بان القانون هو فوق الجميع ولكن
يرى بعض الناس الذين يدعمون ترامب خاصه
بان القانون اصبح انتقائي وهنا تكمن
المشكله عند الحزب الديمقراطي في اقناع
شريحه واسعه من المجتمع الامريكي بان هذا
القانون يسري على الجميع يعني بالامس كنا
نرى بان هنالك تسريب لوثائق سريه من ضابط
صغير جندي صغير حتى في واشنطن كيف توصلت
هذه
الوثائق السريه جدا الى هذا الشخص الذي
وضعها على الوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وقراها جميع لعده اشهر قبل ان تتحرك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والقضاء للقبض
عليه ومحاكمته طبعا هنالك ما يحصل اليوم
هو هنالك محكمتين محكمه رسميه
توجه اليه الاتهامات وهنالك محكمه شعبيه
بانتظاره في نوفمبر 202 اذا ربح المحكمه
الشعبيه ستسقط المحكمه الرسميه حكما وهذا
يعمل عليه الحزب الديمقراطي بان يستبق هذه
المحكمه الشعبيه
ويمنع دان ترامب من الترشح او من التمكن
في الوصول الى البيت سيد ايهاب انتقل اليك
يعني ترامب يتحدث
عن
سياسي ضد حزب وفعليا اذا كان ترامب يمتلك
الحق في تهمى هل
يعني ينفذ من كل التهم الموجهه اليه
اهلا بحضرتك
الاستاذ طاهر وبضيف الكريمه وبكل
المشاهدين يعني دعينا في البدايه نقول
انما يحدث اليوم هو في مصلحه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بكل تاكيد دعايه قويه
جدا لهذا الرجل ولديه اليوم حمله انتخابيه
من الناحيه الماديه قويه جدا تبرعات تاتيه
من كل صوب واتجاه من داخل الولايات
المتحده فيما يتعلق بمحاولات الادانه
طالما ترامب لم تتم ادانته فهو بخير بمعنى
هو بخير سياسيا يعني يستطيع ان يترشح عن
الحزب الجمهوري ويخوض الانتخابات
التمهيديه ومن ثم اذا فاز طبقا لتوقعات
استطاعات الراي سيكون مرشحا امام المرشح
الديمقراطي الاخر الذي من الممكن ان يكون
هو الرئيس ايضا
في نهايه المطاف ومن الممكن ان يفوز
ويمارس مهام منصبه من السجن فكل ما لم
يقتل دونالد ترامب سياسيا هو يقويه بكل
تاكيد ونحن في هذه المرحله من احدى هذه
المراحل
نظام 2016 وحتى اليوم محاولات لادانته في
كثير من القضايا كلها تقريبا فشلت اتحدث
عن القضايا التي من الممكن ان تدور بسمعته
السياسيه والتي تدور بصنعته في اطار ان
يكون موظفا فيدراليا وبمن في هذه الوظائف
وظيفه رئيس الدوله الامريكيه اذا هو حتى
اللحظه لم تتم ادانته وصحيح هناك لائحه
اتهام وسنتعرف على هذه الائحه اللائحه
اكثر بعد ساعات صباح او يوم غد باذن الله
لنتعرف على مدى قدره هذه اللائحه في ان
تضيف جديدا
للاتهامات ولمحاولات الادانه التي
وجهت له خلال الفترات الماضيه دون جدوى
ولكن هل تعتقد بانه يمكن يعني تسييس الامر
الى هذا الحد في بلد مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نحن نتحدث عن قضاء عن هيئه
محلفين عن نظام قضائي يعني لا يمكن ان او
او انت تصحح لنا اذا كان يمكن ان يخترقوا
الفساد السياسي بين قوسين ان صحت هذه
التهم كيف يمكن ان نرد عليها لو سمحت
فقط بان الوان المتحده الامريكيه لديها
مؤسسات
وهنالك يعني قول باللغه الانجليزيه يقول
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لها
مؤسسات شكا يعني انه هنالك من يراقب
وهنالك من يفعل والذي يفعل يراقب الذي لا
يفعل والذي لا يفعل يراقب الذي يفعل طيب
هنا اليوم امام اتهامات لرئيس سابق يعني
هذه هذه غير مسبوقه في الزمن هذا الذي
نعيشه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي يعني
بعيده عن ان تستخدم اي شيء في السياسه هل
السياسه كل شيء في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يستخدم في السياسه انا لا اتهم
الولايات اي حزب ديمقراطي او جمهوري بانه
يستخدم هذا الموضوع في السياسه ولكن
يبدو بان هذه الاتهامات جاءت بعد ان اعلن
دانا ترامب نيته وبعد ان مرشح رئاسي لماذا
هنالك سؤال يطرح يعني انا لست من مؤيدين
ولا اريد يصبح رئيسا على مستوى الشخصي
ولكن ارى بان يعني انه القول بان الولايات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا يمكن ان
تستخدم اي شيء في السياسه والمؤسسات
الامريكيه لا تستخدم اي شيء في السياسه
نحن العرب الامريكيون اليوم نرزح تحت
طائله يعني اتهامات منذ 11 ايلول وما قبل
11 ايلول ولكن اشتدت بعد على المطارات على
المداخل والمخارج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نعامل بطريقه باننا متهمين بدون
ادله يعني طبعا كل شيء يستخدم في انتقل
الى ايهاب سيد ايهاب يعني لنشركوا تفضل
انا اعتقد بانه المحكمه في النهايه
ستحكم بالعداله يعني انا وهنالك محكمه شعب
محكمه الشعب ايضا لا يمكن محكمه الشعب
ستقول رايها في
الاقتراع هذا واضح سيد ايهاب يعني فعليا
هناك نظريه تقول بانه يمكن لترامب ان يقبل
او يعترف بانه مذنب مقابل استمراره في هذا
السباق الرئاسي هل هذا السيناريو وارد
برايك
لا غير وارد بكل تاكيد لان ترامب يعني حتى
لو تمت ادانته فهو يستطيع ان يستمر في
السباق الرئاسي
وعلى المستوى الشخصي دونالد ترامب شخصيه
يعني لا تتقبل الهزيمه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بسمعته وهذا الرجل كافح خلال عشرات
السنوات فيما يتعلق بسمعته اتفقنا او
اختلفنا مع تصرفاته التي ادين بها تاره في
قضايا ليست ذات صله سياسيه او لم تتم
ادانته الا انه لديه شخصيه وكاريزما اذا
ما اعترف بهذا الامر هو سيفقد الملايين من
المؤيدين
والناخبين الذين سيصوتون له لا يقبل اي
نوع من انواع التسويه وهو يعلم جيدا انه
لن يذهب الى السجن في نهايه المطاف ليس
فقط بسبب ان هناك حشد اليوم كبير جدا
للجماهير الامريكيه المتعاطفه معه حتى
يعني بدانا نلاحظ لهجه عدوانيه الكثير من
التصريحات هناك من يقول اجعلوها دماءا في
دماءا في دماء وهناك من يطالب بالقضاء على
اليسريين والشيوعين الى اخره كما يصفونهم
لكن بسبب ان دونالد ترامب قضائيا لن تتم
الادانه من وجهه نظري بهذه السهوله لديه
فريق محامين قوي جدا كل القضايا التي او
كل اتهامات التي هي مثاره ضدهم حتى اللحظه
لا توجد فيها ادله قويه جدا من الممكن ان
تؤدي الى عموما وسنكون معكما ومع بقيه
ضيوفنا الكرام لمتابعته شكرا جزيلا لك
ايهاب عباس الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن شكرا كذلك
الاستاذ اسامه سبلاني الناشر ورئيس تحرير
صحيفه صدى وطن من واشنطن تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
اذا المتحدث باسم الامم المتحده يقول ان
المبعوث الاممي الى السودان فولكر بيرس
موجود ويعمل حاليا في نيروبي ومستمرون في
النقاش مع السلطات السودانيه حول عده
قضايا سنتابع في هذا الموضوع اذا من قول
المتحدث باسم الامم المتحده ايضا بانه
المنظمه ستشارك في استضافه مؤتمر رفيع
المستوى للاعلان عن تعهدات لدعم الاستجابه
الانسانيه في السودان في التاسع عشر من
يونيو وستشارك المنظمه في استضافه
الفعاليه في جناف مع حكومات السعوديه ومصر
وقطر والمانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
كان رئيس المفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى
فقي حذر من اندلاع حرب اهليه في السودان
وانتشار الفوضى في حال لم تنتهي الحرب
وقال فك في كلمه له خلال انعقاد مؤتمر
للايجاد ان الاتحاد الافريقي يشجع على
حوار وطني شامل يقوده السودانيون بانفسهم
الازمه العميقه والعنفه في السودان
والتهديدات الخطيره التي تمثلها لوجود هذه
البلاد والمنطقه كلها واضحه جدا كل
التحليلات تتفق على ان هذه الحرب في حال
لم تتوقف ستفدي لاندلاع حرب اهليه وستعم
الفوضى كما انها ستؤدد انهيار الدوله
بالكامل الاليه الثلاثيه التزمت بتوفير
الدامد السودان بوقف الحرب وتوفير
المساعدات الانسانيه لكل من يحتاج اليها
كما تلتزم بمساعده السودانيين الى الذهاب
نحو حوار وطني شامل ومخطط يقوده
السودانيون انفسهم بعيدا عن اي تاثيرات
خارجيه
القتال في الهجوم المضاده الذي تاخذه
اوكرانيا صعب ولكنه يمضي قدما وفقا لاخر
تصريحات الاخرى باكون معكم لنتابع ايضا في
العربيه 360 في اسبانيا عروس بحر حقيقيه
حتى لو فقدت جامعه اطافها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد توفي رئيس الوزراء
الايطالي الاسبق والملك السابق ايضا لفريق
ميلان سيلفيو سكوني عن عمر ناهز 86 عاما
وقد نعته رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلوني باعتباره واحدا من اكثر الرجال
نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا الحديثه
يوجه خطاب ناريا لحشد من مناصريه او يتوسط
قاده مجموعه العشرين لالتقاط صوره تذكاريه
يتبادل اطراف الحديث معبوت او يستقبل
الزعيم الليبي الراحل معمر القذافي وقد
يتلقى لكمه في حفل فتسيل الدماء من وجهه
او يعتمر خوذه لمساعده فريق القضب يتصدر
اسمه الصحف بسبب فضائح واتهامات جنسيه
وتتم مسالته في البرلمان ويمثل امام
المحاكم هذه مشاهد من حياه من يوصف بانه
اكثر الرجال نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا
المعاصر سيلفيو الذي ظل متمسكا بطموحه
السياسي حتى اخر ايامه داعيا مناصريه
للاقتراع في الانتخابات البلديه عبر شريط
فيديو سجله من المستشفى
اعتذر على ازعاجكم ولكن اود تذكيركم ان
الاحد والاثنين اي بعد غد وفي اليوم الذي
يليه هناك انتخابات اداريه لرؤساء
البلديات في 700 بلده ومدينه في ايطاليا
يعتبر بيرلس كوني احد الرجال الاكثر ثراء
في بلاده يمتلك اكبر شبكه تلفزيونيه
تجاريه والعديد من الاستثمارات الاخرى دخل
معترك السياسه عام
وحكمك رئيس وزراء لتسع سنوات كان لها
التاثير الاعمق في وجه ايطاليا المعاصر
اود ان اقول ان بيرلس كوني كان له تاثير
هائل بشكل عام على الثقافه الايطاليه اي
على عقليه الناس عندما ادخل بيرلس كون
التلفزيون التجاري في بدايه الثمانينيات
كانت ايطاليا منقسمه بشكل اساسي بين
الثقافه الكاثوليكيه التقليديه والثقافه
الشيوعيه اليسريه وقد قدم بيرلس كوني نوعا
جديدا من الفكر التقدمي وقاد عمليه
التغيير نحو مجتمع مدني
وجاب بيرلس كوني في سنواته الاخيره فضائح
جنسيه واتهم فساد برئ منها وانتخب عضوا في
مجلس الشيوخ وقد احتفظ الرجل بمكانه خاصه
في قلوب ملايين الايطاليين وتحديدا مشجعي
فريق ميلان الذي امتلكه برلسكوني اللي
نحوي ثلاثين عاما وحقق معه الكثير من
البطولات قبل بيعه لمستثمرين صيني
كشف طيران الرياض عن تصميم الهويه البصريه
والفئه الاولى من التصميم الخارجي لاسطول
طائرته على ان يتم اعلان التصميم الثاني
في المستقبل القريب حيث تم اطلاق حفل
تدشين الهويه البصريه والكشف عن التصميم
الخارجي للطائره في مطار الرياض
ليمثل احتفال العاصمه السعوديه بالناقل
الوطني الجديد
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 الولايات
المتحده تنوير انضمام الينا مجددا اعتبارا
من يوليو القادم تصريح للمدير العامه
لليونسكو اودري ازولاي التي اعتبرت ايضا
ان الخطوه الامريكيه تعكس الثقه في
اليونسكو وتعدديه المنظمه لكن ما لم تذكره
ازولاي ان الانسحاب الامريكي تم في عام
2018 بسبب منح المنظمه فلسطين العضويه
الكامله وانها تعود بسبب الخوف من ان تملا
الصين الفراغ الامريكي داخل المنطقه او
المنظمه
والى فيديو اليوم من اسبانيا في الثالثه
والعشرين تداعب سار الامواج وكانها تداعب
عروستها الصغيره القت ابنه بكل ذكرياتها
المرهقه في المياه كيف تمكن منها التهاب
السحايا وتركها مبتوره اليدين والقدمين
وبكليه واحده قليله الحيله في نظر البعض
صارت بطله في هذه الرياضه وحققت الميداليه
الفضيه في بطوله العالم لتقدم درسا جديدا
من دروس البشر للبشر رفضت الفتاه الصغيره
نظرات الاستعلاء من البعض والشفقه من
البعض الاخر واجبرتهم على ان يروها كما
ارادت ان يروها عروس بحر حقيقيه
رائعه سوره اليوم من اوكرانيا تتكرر هذه
الصفوف الطويله في خرسون فقد حصلتهم مياه
الفيضانات ارضا بعد انهيار سد نوفاكا ولم
تتاخر عليهم مياه الامطار الغزيره من
يصطفون وسط كل هذا في انتظار ما يسد رمقهم
من مراكز الاغاثه لدى كل منهم الم جرى
الحرب لكنه الام لا يغرق مهما كثرت المياه
سيظل طافيا هو اخف من ان يغرق لكنه كذلك
اثقل من ان يحتمل
هكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام العربيه 360
باخبارها وملفاتها ونقلها المباشر ايضا
ونتابع اولا باول عبر العربيه كل ما
سيردون عن هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه لدونالد
ترامب امام محكمه فيدراليه فلوريدا حيث
وصل مع بدايه هذه الساعه اما من سيتابع في
هذا فهو صهيب شراير معه اخبار الساعه
اضافه الى ملفات اخرى كثيره اليس كذلك
صحيح مساء الخير راويه وطاهر محاكمه ترامب
في ميامي ستبقى خبر الساعه لدينا كذلك قصه
تبدو من الصباح يعني يتم الحديث عنها
ارتفاع اسعار تذاكر الطيران رغم تحسن
الاوضاع واسعار النفط كل هذا يلقي بظلاله
كذلك على العطل الصيفيه القادمه الكلمه لك
تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات